Speaking, by the way, of drugs, Donald Trump
Junior was now asked when he was on Fox and
Friends yesterday morning whether his tirade
speech at the Republican National Convention
on Monday night was filled by cocaine, and
he has since denied it.
Now, last night was night three of the Republican
National Convention.
But if you think back to the first night,
there were many questions raised about the
insanity of Donald Trump junior speech and
also the speech of his girlfriend, Kimberly
Guilfoyle.
The content was, of course, completely unhinged,
but the delivery also raised questions about
upper use because both Don Junior and Kimberly
Guilfoyle seemed completely shot out of cannons.
Kimberly Guilfoyle screaming uncontrollably,
which we'll get to Don Junior.
His eyes almost swollen, completely shut.
Almost like a frothing at the mouth delivery.
Well, Donald Trump Junior is now denying that
his speech was fueled by cocaine.
And this is one of those things where if you're
even talking about this, maybe there's a problem.
Here is Don Junior himself answering the questions
about this yesterday on Fox and Friends.
You were one of the keynote speakers on the
first night, Monday night.
And speaking of the media, I afterwards I
saw that the main concern was why were his
eyes so glassy?
Well, I guess there must have been something
with the lighting.
But they started doing this trending thing.
Donald Trump Junior is on cocaine and all
that.
I said, no, no, no.
You have me confused with Hunter Biden.
Oh, it was it was pretty ridiculous, you know,
so when they can't attack the delivery, when
they can't attack the substance, they've got
to attack something just like Bette Midler
and all of these WOAK Hollywood ites last
night attacking Melania because she didn't
speak English the same way that they would.
Well, she speaks five languages.
She's from a foreign country.
She got up on a world stage and knocked it
out of the park.
But you know what?
Attack her.
It's ridiculous.
It's the same as watching the DNC attacking
the RNC because the RNC has the gall to showcase
real Americans who have benefited for Donald
Trump's policies, who have benefited from
this administration rather than the out of
touch Hollywood celebrities that they put
on their never ending Zoome call of I Hate
America last week.
It's truly mind boggling how out of touch
the Democrats are.
They don't even see it.
It's an asinine notice that Don Junior doesn't
say.
I've never done cocaine or I don't do cocaine.
He simply says I was not on Coke that night.
But Hunter Biden was something about the lighting,
made him look like maybe he was on Coke, I
guess.
And the more I think about it, if I were a
public figure and someone asked me about an
interview during an interview about whether
I was on cocaine during a speech and if it
was really bogus, I don't think I would dignify
it with a response.
I don't know about you.
I would say that's absolutely absurd.
It's being asserted without evidence, and
I'm not even going to dignify that with a
response.
There is also video from before Don Junior
went on of him drinking two Red Bulls.
So maybe it's just Red Bull.
Maybe it was Red Bull and something else.
I don't know.
But take a look at this.
Guys, Donald Trump, junior here, superexcited
first night of the RNC 2020, getting amped
up and ready for my speech.
It's going to be awesome.
Now, just a reminder, here is one of the most
unhinged moments from Don Junior speech.
Just so you know, this has not been sped up
or in any way.
You'll notice if you're watching Don Junior
swollen eyes and just a lot of other weird
details.
Imagine the life you want to have.
One with a great job, a beautiful home, a
perfect family.
You can have it.
Imagine the country you want to live in, one
with true equal opportunity where hard work
pays off and justice is served with compassion
and without partiality.
You can have it.
Imagine a world where the evils of communism
and radical Islamic terrorism are not given
a chance to spread.
Where heroes are celebrated.
And the good guys win.
You can have it.
That is the life.
That is the country.
That is the world that Donald Trump and the
Republican Party are after.
And yes, you can have it, because unlike Joe
Biden and the radical left Democrats, our
party is open to everyone.
It starts by rejecting radicals who want to
drag us into the dark and embracing the man
who represents a bright and beautiful future
for all.
And then even more outrageously, here is Kimberly
Guilfoyle, just screaming at the top of her
lungs.
Ladies and gentlemen, leaders and fighters
for freedom and liberty and the American dream.
The best is yet to come.
So if lighting is the only explanation, I
want to talk to the gaffer and see how he
was able to achieve that look.
But here's here's what I really want to focus
on.
First of all, it's insane that this is even
something that's being discussed.
Fine.
But more importantly, isn't it really weird
that when Don Junior was asked about it, he
doesn't deny using cocaine?
He says it was the lights and Hunter Biden
actually does cocaine?
I find that to be a really strange reaction.
And then the top level thought that I had
was I considered drug addiction to be a medical
issue.
It's not something we laugh at.
It's not something we make fun of.
And when Don Junior makes this comment about
Hunter Biden, Hunter Biden has spoken about
living with drug addiction.
And Don Junior is essentially making fun of
someone in recovery from drug addiction.
And that's really the disgust, the most disgusting
aspect of this.
So this entire episode is another confirmation
that money can't really buy class and that
an expensive education also doesn't guarantee
empathy, both things that we probably knew
before the Trump presidency, but have been
made even more clear.
But in any case, for all of you who e-mailed
me about what Don and Kimberly were on Monday
night, he denies that it was cocaine